Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host, Rawkode. Although, to my
wife and kids, David Flanagan,
and to my neighbors in this office box,
the guy that has been playing Linkin Park
far too loud for the last forty eight
hours. So welcome back.
Today, are carrying on with a Rawkode live
series in which we take a look at
awesome projects and cloud native and wider space
that help make building distributed systems easier. And
today, we are taking a look at Restate,
which is found at Restate.dev,
and I am joined
by one of the maintainers
Hi.
How's it How's it going? Not too bad.
Not too bad. How are you?
Yeah.
Just enjoying the day. It's a nice easy
start to the week, especially when I get
to sit in front of the camera and
play with some awesome technology.
But before we get into that, why don't
you tell us a little bit about you?
Sure. Yeah. So I'm Jack.
I'm a senior engineer at Restate. I focus
mostly on the cloud platform and the Go
SDK and a little bit of the TypeScript
SDK, which I think we'll be getting into
today.
I spent pretty much my entire career in
cloud native
starting off at Monzo
where I was doing, like, security for Kubernetes,
basically.
And that was pretty fun because we have
literally 1,500
services at the time, and I think now
they're, like, 3,000.
Actually went really viral on Twitter, like, four
years ago for tweeting an image of all
of our services talking to each other, and
all these people were retweeting it being like,
this is such a bad design and trends
and failures are gonna destroy you, all those
kinds of stuff. I'm like, oh, wait. The
retry failure application.
And so that's kind of what started to
get me really passionate about, like, making distributed
systems work,
removing these problems, distracting them away.
After that, went to Apple. I worked at
SRE.
I saw what it's like to, like, really
maintain extremely large complicated systems, like highly multi
tenant teams, teams that maybe don't do always
the right thing. And that was really fun
as well.
Yeah. That that led me to Restate where,
I guess, our mission is to try and
make it easier to build complex interrelated systems.
I mean, even when you have two processes
running on the same machine,
you have an system that can fail in
their communication. Then you have two different machines
against even worse and two different data centers
in two different countries.
So many companies
are struggling with just splitting one process into
two, and I guess Restate is
trying to make those things a lot better
than they were before.
So yeah. That's funny. So is the TLDR
from that that we should just build monolithic
applications and deploy them on a single box?
I think if that box is a mainframe,
then yes. I think absolutely.
I mean, I guess for me, like, the
pitch I always had at Monzo was Microsoft's
weren't solving a
tech problem there. They were solving, like, an
organizational problem. Like, they made it so much
easier
to have teams that don't have to, like,
have shared design reviews or have, like Yeah.
Shared,
you know, complexity, a lot lots of concern
about,
shared libraries and things like that. Instead, we
just had these really simple RPC contracts,
and teams could just develop really quickly independently.
And that's what got me hooked on this.
And,
yeah, to make that work, you need this,
like, incredible platform team, and they were they
were so good, the team of the Monzo.
And and, yeah, that's what got me passionate
about. Like, if you can make the platform
good enough,
then you can get it to the point
that it's almost as technically good as being
on a mainframe, like massive IBM machine.
But you get these massive development developer experience
advantages if you can allow teams to operate
independently and so on.
So, yeah, that's my mission really is to
make to make this better.
Nice. I love that we have very similar
mission. I mean, I think we've both been
on this cloud now space for a while.
And I always tell people that microservices
microservices
are are really simple. That's the whole point
of them. Right? You're supposed to be able
to fit them in your head and be
able to rewrite them rather than change them,
but that complexity doesn't disappear. It's it's been
pushed down to platform and infrastructure layers where
they have to build a lot of tooling
and automation and remediation.
Everything has to happen there. But as in
the let's make developers' lives easier. Let's have
them focus on what they enjoy doing.
And I think, yes, there's
there's a lot of trade offs of every
approach to building software.
But I think in 2024, when we have
things like Restate and other tools, as we'll
see today,
these harder challenges are getting easier too, which
is wonderful, and I'm excited to share that
with people.
Absolutely.
Yeah. So the methodology that it seems to
exist, like, in the world and what I've
always experienced is, like, you have some kind
of mismatch of, like, k v stores,
queues,
RPC frameworks,
retries,
and the end result can be, like, really
reliable and really good. But that's quite a
lot of mental load for engineers, and they
have to worry about things like added potency
and just lots of new concepts. So
my hope is that we can start to
unify some of these tools together
and just
bring the code back to being 95%
business logic. You can never pretend that the
distribution system's not there or, like, the network
isn't there. That's it's it's fantasy. But can
we get much more of the proportion of
the code to be
business logic and not
instantiate Kafka client or, you know, is this
a retry or check the token against the
DB to see if we failed? These sorts
of things
occupy a lot of time
at microservices businesses, and that's that's what I
like to sort out.
Nice. Now I I don't wanna spoil too
much for the people that are watching, but
I will clarify that I am using Restate
right now in the Rawkode Academy infrastructure.
And the first thing we deployed
was turned out to be the easiest kind
of code I've ever read in my life,
but it's actually quite complicated what's happening underneath
the hood. And it's what when people register
for the Rawkode Academy website,
we also create a user account for them.
But we don't activate their account until they've
verified their email address. And we were able
to hook that up at one lane of,
like, recent magical magic
that just kinda sits there forever and says,
I'm gonna wait until you've proven to me
that this account is active. It is astounding
to see. And Yep. We're gonna show And
this is all running serverless as well. Right?
So when we say wait, what do we
really mean? I guess we'll get into that,
but that's that's the exciting thing.
Awesome.
Alright.
So I've went on a tangent already. Let's
back up a bit for people that are
watching, and they're still like, wait. What what
the fuck is a Restate? Like, maybe we
can give them the the patch. What what
does Restate deliver for the average developer that
wants to build fault on distributed systems?
Yeah. So
guess I'll start with the sort of the
primitive that we offer, and then I'll I'll
maybe I can go into, like, how it
fits inside the infrastructure. So so what we
offer is
suspendable functions. And what I mean by that
is
code that can save its progress kind of
at any point,
and resume later. So if you've come from
a Go background, this might sound a little
bit like a distributed coroutine.
If you come from a JavaScript
background, maybe you might think of this as
being like a distributed async run time or,
like, async event loop.
And, yeah, this is a
little bit of a new concept, but the
idea is that when your program fails, for
example, like, the machine dies or crashes, we
can resume from that point onwards. But it's
a lot more interesting than just failure because
there's also this idea of, like, sometimes
code, it's a lot more helpful if you
could just think of it as waiting for
something, like, for a long time, like, even
for a week. And you can't really write
code that way because you're guaranteed to hit
some kind of infrastructure failure if you wait
for long enough.
Or if you're running serverless, you're being billed
by the second. So the fact that the
code can sort of invisibly or somewhat invisibly
save its progress, shut down, and then resume
at that point at a later date when
the thing it's waiting for is done, that's
really useful primitive. Sounds like that's the one
that you were using, which I mentioned we'll
go into. But,
so that's that's what we're trying to offer.
The way that it works is by writing
down more. So applications right now,
are not particularly stateful, or we don't see
them as being super stateful other than what
they save in the database. And saving something
in the database is something that engineers have
to, like, deliberately do.
And kind of the more you write down
or the more you say, the better. And
when we write to Kafka, we are also
writing something down. I mean, it it it
may not feel that way, but Kafka is
like a durable
log and can actually store messages for a
really long time. Right?
So
we are making it much easier to write
things down.
For example, when you make an RPC between
two services, that's gonna be persisted.
When you do something
like, create an item potency token, that's gonna
be persisted,
and lots of other things as well. And
we try and do this without really changing
the way you write code at all.
The end result is that the program can
be stopped
and then resumed and all the previous values
filled in and then continue from where it
was. And that's what allows us to do
things like sleep for a week or or
wait for a user input for a year.
I mean, these sorts of suspendable properties are
really helpful, but it's also really helpful
for failure of any kind. I mean, obviously,
some types of failure, like user failures,
like
or, like, the infrastructure just isn't running. These
things are difficult to deal with, but things
like the network failing or the user closing
the browser tab or these sorts of things.
By writing more down, we can allow complex
workflows to resume from the point to which
they failed.
And this makes it a lot easier to
reason about idempotency because if you think about,
like, 10 steps
and you get to the ninth, if we
then start from the beginning, making that whole
thing idempotent is quite tricky. But with Restate,
you kind of only have to worry about
that last step. Like, maybe it could be
run again if it, like, failed before we
managed to save the result, but we know
that the previous steps that were saved, they
will never run again. And that's makes things
a lot easier for engineers.
So this is sort of Can I challenge
one of the things you said there? Yep.
You said that it doesn't change the way
that we write code. And I've actually found
no. I'm saying I'm gonna say you're wrong,
but I kinda am. Right? I've
actually found this made my code a lot
simpler because we have this linear flow of
what things are supposed to do, and I
found myself I've not had to reach for,
like, state machines and complex modeling of these
situations anymore because we are able to map
things as a linear progression of events.
And I have found that things are are
just a lot easier. I'm not sitting there
going, oh, I'm in this You're right. Waiting
for activation,
and I'm not having to worry about item
potency of the first nine steps. You're right.
Like, that is a challenge, but that that
suspendable linear progression does change the way that
we write code, but for the better, I
drastically
So I think what I really mean is
you don't have to write the code much
differently to if it was just running on
your laptop. And, for example, waiting for input,
it was just the process was just waiting
or sleeping for a month. It was just
sleeping, you kept it on under your desk
or whatever, which is a perfectly fine way
to write software. But the moment that you
go serverless or really into any, like, Kubernetes
environment, all these things become somewhat impossible. So
that's the world we want. It's, like, super
imperative,
like, coding on a Commodore sixty four.
The thing that the code says it's doing
is what it's doing.
The right way to do it without Restate,
as you said, is, like, actors
and
queues
and complex
systems, and they do change the way you
write code. And there's absolutely nothing wrong with
them. They are amazing tools, but our hope
is that we can distill down their properties
with a different API.
And maybe that brings me on to
the position of the infrastructure because, essentially,
we do look a little bit like a
a message queue. We look a little bit
like a Kafka. We're a stateful message queue.
It's a streaming system,
and we have similar properties to if you
split your application up into lots of event
handlers that, you know, every single step is
its own event handler, and you would just
kind of hop between each step with the
state that needs to be sent between each
step. And that, by the way, is exactly
how we built complex distributed systems at Monzo,
was, we would just put everything into handlers.
If it needs to be reliable, it's in
another handler. And that is really a lot
lot harder. So, yeah, that's what I'm excited
about is is maybe you can just write,
do this thing, then do this thing,
then wait for this thing for a week,
then sleep,
whatever you wanna do. And it it would
just look like the simplest code, but
has different properties.
Alright. I'm I'm really disappointed that we're fifteen
minutes in and no one has said rushed
yet. So I just thought I'd get that
out of the way.
I try not to go that long with
it. That's true.
But we get we get criticized for for
advertising that we're for Rust. And part of
the reason for that was that until about
this week, we didn't have a Rust SDK.
So now we do. We can say that
we're There's a Rust SDK.
That is as of, like, right now. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay. That's just changed the entire session.
Okay. Well, maybe we should talk about that
as well. But
we have been criticized in the past because
it's like, yeah, you're building with Rust, but
you're not building for Rust people. Okay. Well,
now we are. But but it's true that
our first SDKs with Java and TypeScript, now
we also have Go, Python, and and Rust.
So things are expanding expanding fast on that
front. I think there's obviously a lot of
frustration in the developer community where people are
rewriting things in Rust that maybe don't need
to be re rewritten in Rust. But I
think something like Restate should be written in
Rust, but it doesn't necessarily mean the end
consumer
is gonna be written all their stuff and
Rust. And I think I think they need
to know TypeScript is yeah. Yeah. I don't
think they need to mind, but I think
the the really exciting thing about Restate from,
like, a operator perspective is that it's like
a single binary.
It's really easy to get running. Like, you
can run it on your machine. That's not
like the dev server. When you type restate
dash server presenter, you're running, like, the actual
thing, and it's once exactly the same way
on your laptop as it would when it's
running on cloud or when it's running, like,
on the AWS box or whatever.
And I think that's that's cool, and and
Rust gives us a lot of nice properties
there about it being
very low dependency.
And we don't we don't ever wanna have
to rely on, an external, like, etcd or
something like that, partly because, you know, several
of us at Restate have had a really
negative experiences running complex distributed systems that have,
like, 10 components and and rely on, like,
other distributed systems as well and so on.
So we want it to be so easy
to operate,
and we also want it to be really,
really, really fast. Like, we want
complex workflows to have single
digit millisecond overhead
from all of the writing things down. And
to do that, you need to build a
new kind of streaming storage system
and making that distributed and fault tolerant and
still really performant.
It's not very easy. And, unfortunately, I have
some smart people working on that.
And they are using Rust, and thank thank
goodness for that because I think it's it's
a big help on performance for sure. And
I can't write C plus plus to save
my life, so I don't know what else
we'd be doing. Yeah. Rest is a great
language for it, especially with SPTK and IO
integration.
It's like right into Linux disks. It's just
never been faster. There's a lot of really
exciting work going in that space.
Yep. Now I'll just I'll call it out
because you didn't. You know, I'm gonna say
all nine out of ten nine out of
10 times problems with distributed systems as etcd.
Like, it's not set for purpose. We should
not be running it. I don't know why
we're in this situation with Kubernetes. You're right.
Even better is when you have your DNS
backed by then you're really winning. But, yeah,
I mean, god, it's such a nightmare to
run. And I'm so glad that we don't
rely on anything like that. Zookeeper is worse.
I think it's fair to say. At least
Kafka is fine. We got off of that
one. Yeah. I I do like that Kafka
when start using Kafka for that rather than
think that's why I I stopped using Kafka
because of those Zookeeper stuff. I had too
many problems. I I started looking out there.
Red Panda is a great one. It it
requires Zookeeper.
We've taken a lot of inspiration from them.
They're also obsessive about this zero dependency, simple
single binary, this kind of stuff. This is
really, really awesome. Except they went c plus
plus and you went to rest. So Yeah.
Exactly.
Alright. Russell's in the chat saying, so this
is the async of event
driven programming.
Right? Absolutely.
I often use this expression distributed async await,
but it doesn't mean something to everyone.
And I think this is something we struggle
with in Restate because depending on what language
you come from, I should probably be using
different words.
And that the SDK is also, of course,
different depending on the languages, but we're not
like, the thing we're really passionate about is
the runtime and, like, the thing that makes
this performant and successful. And we want the
SDK to be whatever makes sense to our
users, but it help it hurts us in
communication because,
yeah, async gateway turns off anyone who doesn't
like async gateway, which is, like, I don't
know, half of engineers, maybe.
Alright.
Well, I am gonna get my screen ready
for us to start taking a look at
the docs and and show people where they
can get started with us as well.
So,
yeah, thank you, Russell, for jumping in the
chat, and then someone confirmed that. I don't
know if Ahmed is maybe on the Restate
team for Yes. He's a he's a principal
engineer working on the runtime.
If we have any really complex questions about
the distributed architecture, you know, maybe he could
reply in the comments.
And do we have anyone here that's gonna
tell us how to work the Rust SDK?
Because now that's the only thing I want
to do.
Definitely not me, but I'm never trying it
so far. I have no idea who's watching.
No one hasn't ever changed it. I thought
let's let's try. We'll do a second one.
Don't worry.
Alright. I am gonna throw up the screen
share,
and we can just talk about how people
get started with that. I mean, it's our
NF and I've messed up. We haven't covered.
Like, how do you feel that we've given
people a good overview of what Restate is
and what are levers? Yeah. I hope so.
Righty.
So here is the Restate.dev
website.
It is one point o
with a cloud offering and seed funding.
I mean, it feels to me that Restate
is about two weeks old. I know I
know it's not because we've been chatting for
a while now,
but it's been I mean, you did not
waste time getting to that one point o,
I've gotta say. Like, a lot of projects
these days, especially in cloud native, I feel
like they've been around for ten years and
they're still in zero point twelve point one
seven six.
Like Yep. Clearly, you said a mission and
you're like, we want to deliver best. This
is what we're gonna deliver, and we got
there. Maybe you could talk about that. Mission.
And and really what we know is about
stability promises, and that's that's really scary and
stressful thing. It's an early stage startup. It's
like, are we sure that our feature surface
now is the one that we want to,
like, stand by for
I don't know how long.
But, yeah, we we have to be stable,
really, to persuade people to rely on us
for them, like, most critical use cases. We're
not like a monitoring tool. If it goes
down, would be really annoying, but you know
or if it changes the API, it would
be annoying, but fundamentally, it's fixable.
We are asking permission to be one of
the most critical components of infrastructure, and that's
why stability is so important.
K. Awesome.
So if we scroll down, you're kind of
already summarizing a few of the main use
cases. We've got workflows
as code, and we can see a nice
example here. I'll quickly work it if I
can see what that's doing.
So you're creating a new Restate service,
and there's a handler.
And then maybe we can just give people
a bit of context on what context dot
run means. I mean, this is how Restate
handles, what, side effects? Is that the right
way to put it? Yeah.
So things that you want to happen ideally
only once.
And once they've happened, we'll save the result,
and we would guarantee that on failure or,
you know, anything like that, it won't need
to happen again and its result will just
be filled in.
Nice.
And there's also the Java example sitting here
front and center, which has already hurt my
eyes. But, you know Yeah. That's the void.
Yeah. I
think that's an important I think that was
a really clever I don't know who it
restates, said list, you know, like, at Java
early. But, know, the enterprise world and the
Java world have been doing
BP and m and workflows and event driven
systems and actor driven system and all this
for decades. Like, this is not new paradigms
for them. So I think that's a really
slick move to just support that world completely.
Also, all of my founders, they built Apache
Flink, which is like a streaming system, which
is all written in Java.
So thank god Restate is not written in
Java because I personally really, really, really hate
Java.
But these
guys really know how to write Java, they
really understand that world. So I think it
was it was always a big priority for
us.
I think Java is is I don't think
I can't personally see it ever getting back
into developer hands. Like, developers are front forward
future facing, front facing, whatever you wanna say.
It just feels like legacy to me, but
then I am wearing a go t shirt.
I am writing Rusty and Day Out. I
am playing with shiny new languages. You know,
I could sit here and talk about pony
lang for the next six weeks, and nobody
would even know what the hell I'm talking
about. But it's a super cool language,
even if slightly academic.
And And I don't know if Java can
make is where where the work is getting
done for most of the world. And,
and I guess for us, like, the more
traditional,
your software systems are, like, the more excited
we are because
I think we have a huge amount of
value to people that are cloud native, many
of those people have already learned how to
solve these problems that I'm discussing. I think
they can solve them easier with Restate. But
there's another group of people that it's like,
they are actually struggling to get off of
mainframes or they are struggling to get off
of monoliths.
And for me, like, that's even more exciting
because there's so much value to be unlocked
there if we can help them do those
things.
Alright. Awesome. I'm gonna pick one more randomly
just to see what code it gives us.
I mentioned state machines, so let's pop that
open. So this one actually has a state
machine example
implemented with a switch case. Not the worst
way to do it. So
there's actually something coming out this week. I
don't know if you you've used xState, The
Yeah. I love x state. I use it
all of them. So
we have made it possible to turn any
x state state machine into a Restate service,
and it can run serverless.
So you can have these, like, virtual state
machines running in the cloud invisibly
and move between these different states, and we
will just store all the results. But the
the critical primitive here that you can see
is context dot set. So
Restate has a type of service called a
virtual object, and those objects have a key.
And therefore, in a sense, they have, like,
unlimited number of objects. Each one kind of
has its own state,
and that's durable. That persists beyond the handler.
I mean, it can exist forever. So you
could use it where you would use Redis.
You could even use it where you would
use Dynamo or, like, any other database just
to keep how you store, essentially.
And
what's cool is
you have, like, guaranteed lock over that state
while your handler is running, and that makes
a lot of things a lot easier. But
because it's specifically on that key, you're not,
like, locking a whole table or anything like
that, and that makes that makes this quite
simple to reason about when you're dealing with,
like, distributed state. So for state machine, it
just means you can just, like, write
the various fields down.
But if you wanna do things really fancy,
we now have this x state integration. And
and there, what we do is we just
basically save the whole state of the x
state state machine to a JSON blob, and
then we rehydrate it whenever the next event
comes in.
That's awesome.
The reason I like Restate is because the
company behind it has the the ability to
actually visualize the state machines in a really
nice way, which is great for documentation.
Absolutely.
And I think we we would also like
to have more in this regard because Restate
has a lot of information about what applications
are doing. We understand these steps,
you know, the run steps and also the
calls between services.
You know, it's actually quite hard to create
a call graph between all of your services.
You can kinda get it out of this
deal and void whatever.
But, like, we have all of this information,
also what you're storing and reading from the
the key value store.
So
we think we could do a really cool
visualization.
So you're gonna provide Amonzo
Death Star as a service for people to
allow them to have their own image of
their architecture.
Yeah. Maybe the cool graph, but also, like,
for individual implication,
what happened? Like, what did it do? Where
did it fail? A little bit like step
function. This is what people love about step
functions. They just hate everything else.
Yeah. So that's what I would like to
have for sure.
Alright. Before we we start typing code, there's
just one other thing that you said that
I wish was interesting. Right? And you said
that there's locking that happens on the key
level.
So does that mean being built in rush,
you're hooking on to, like, I'm assuming Axiom
or some of the other actor primitives
there to give every key message box with
like, if I say update this thing and
then another request comes in, this is update
this thing. You're not dismissing the second one.
It's getting queued and then executed after. Right?
Okay. I think the right way to think
about it is it's as if these RPCs
are going through Kafka in both directions.
But the critical difference, and really wouldn't work
very well with Kafka, is that Kafka would
have partitions to have many keys. Mhmm. And
a single
stuck request or failing request or whatever would
block the whole partition. And you might only
have, I don't know, 64 partitions or something.
So Restate, we don't have header line blocking
like that. So you can only block the
key, which would be the user ID or
whatever. So a user can be in a
bad state,
but not a whole partition. And if you
ever managed Kafka, you would know that these
block partitions are, like, bane of your life.
Yep. I've been there. So,
yeah, so that that's what makes it kind
of possible for for us to not have
these, like, nasty side effects between different users.
So, yeah, it's a it's a pattern I've
actually seen is that people have an RPC
framework where all requests and responses go through
a queue. And that that's essentially the primitive
of how it works, and it gives you
this really nice
linearizability
over a particular user.
Like, for a particular key on a particular
service, they will process every request in sequence.
And that that actually just makes life a
lot easier. It doesn't, in my experience, have
a significant performance impact. And we also have
these shared handlers that get a read only
view of a snapshot of state,
and they can run concurrently.
And
even if you're not doing things with state,
this just gives you, like, a lock primitive,
basically. It gives you, like, a little bit
of a read write lock primitive,
where you can have some handlers that will
always
run only one at a time and some
handlers that can run concurrently, and this is
just
generally,
that's all you need, I find.
Awesome.
Alright. I'll show off the nice diagrams, talk
about Rust a little bit more, and then
let's get into the docs. Okay. Alright.
So our plan today
is really to get people a taste of
how they get started with Restate. What that
local developer experience looks like, how they write
their first durable function,
and then we'll try and later on a
little bit explore new things. So especially trying
to get the concepts and the primitives in
there so that people can just understand that
lingo and then Mhmm. Hopefully start to build
something.
Sounds good. And we said we'd start with
TypeScript.
I mean, is there a magic link for
me to get a Rust SDK? I'm just
asking. I'm not saying we do it.
Not in the docs,
but, you know, maybe soon. I'll send you
something.
Right. Okay. Now, from my end, and I
should have done this in advance, is I
will need to set up a couple of
things because I am on Nexus and I
can't just download planaries like an idiot.
Of course not.
I really yeah.
The daily experience here, I imagine.
No. I mean,
within my own repository, like, I have my
I use dev env, which gives you this
wonderful load next file.
Mhmm. And I use Progen, which generates new
services for me with everything I need. So
it's just I've got it all down.
But I don't like to do too much
in advance before these sessions, but then this
is important for the audience. This is just
me being annoyed. So
and I'm
gonna enable TypeScript and JavaScript. We actually don't
need anything else
from next.
And what I love now why have I
got so many spaces? Oh, there's my mono
repository because I was working on it this
morning. Mhmm.
And then I hit return, and now I
should have
node.
Nice. But I won't have NPM because I
forgot to do
NPM.
Now, normally, I would use button, but I'm
not gonna rock the boat that much today.
So It does actually work, by the way,
for the record.
I
I I just think bun is such a
pleasant tool to Yeah. It's so much easier
to just do bun run for everything. Yeah.
I use it also for demos a lot.
Yeah.
But I wanna the docs are using MPX,
so I wanna just stick with what the
docs are doing. Yeah. Keep it simple. Yeah.
So this gives us our first example, which
is just gonna create a greeter function,
and we can just run these commands like
so.
There there are a whole bunch of examples
and templates. Right? And if people want to
see what else is available,
they come to this examples repository?
Yeah. Exactly.
And the templates are here. So Yeah. So,
also, you can get these templates from the
Restate CLI. So I guess we'll download that
a little bit later. But once you have
that, you can just do Restate Example,
and it can give you, like, a starter
TypeScript repo or it can give you a
starter go or or or really anything. And
that that's often a good way to get
started.
Nice.
Alright. Let's see where we are. We've got
stuff and things. I've got my code. And
if I pull up this template here
let me oh,
I mean, that's the only way to do
it.
Just change the font size.
24 doesn't feel enough today.
Yeah. It's better. It's good.
Do you wanna just walk us through what's
happening here? Then we'll run it and give
people an idea of what's happening what what
it looks like. Absolutely. Yeah. Okay. So,
yeah, let's start at the bottom. So we
are creating a new Restate endpoint.
What we really mean by that is, like,
essentially
a process running on a port, but actually
behind that, there can be any number of
services. This This is a little bit like
a sort of gRPC server,
and all of Restate has these, like, RPC
stuff semantics.
And we bind to that endpoint a service,
which we create in line.
So we mentioned before that there are virtual
objects. There are also services which are unkeyed
and don't have state. And then there are
also workflows,
which are kind of an interesting special case
of virtual objects that can be very useful.
So we create a new service, and we
define it as having the name greeter, and
we give it one handler.
And that handler is greet, and the greet
handler
a handler really is just any function that
accepts
the context
or for a staple handler. It might be
an object context,
and
any input parameter can be a string, can
be an object with fields. It doesn't really
matter. This is all gonna be encoded by
default with JSON, but this is also configurable.
And then handlers can just return or throw.
So it's quite a simple way of defining
handlers. It's probably recognizable if you've come from,
like, the tRPC world.
Yep. And through TypeScript type magic,
exactly like tRPC,
you can have clients for other services and
the types kind of all work, which is
really nice. And actually, in many ways, it's
a better experience than almost any other language
we have an SDK for because TypeScript is
so powerful for this Yeah.
Which is really cool. So, yeah, that's it.
And then at the end, we're listening on
ninety eighty, which is the port that we
we tend to use. And the way Restate
works from architecture perspective, I I recognize I
didn't say this before,
Restate calls your services. So it's not quite
like a queue in the sense that you
create workers and, like, pull down messages and
process them.
You can actually run your pods,
like, kind of fairly normally, including behind load
balances,
and Restate will just call them over HTTP
two. But you don't call your services directly.
It needs to be called through re the,
like, the Restate binary because Restate is doing
this, like, magical stuff behind the scenes.
And and in fact, you can have a
long lived HTTP request to Restate, and it
might make lots of short invocations to your
underlying service. It might be making Lambda invocations.
You know, there might be thousands of such
invocations, but to you, it just looks like
a sim simple, you know, HTTP request.
So that's that's roughly how the protocol works.
Yeah. In this case, we're serving on ITT.
Thanks.
So I'm gonna just copy this because there's
one thing I think we'll say, right, is
that
Restate isn't particularly
opinionated in how you structure your codes. Like
like you said, you write your code your
own way. Right? So if I call this
Scotland, I will need to obviously go and
Restate again,
is that you can just structure your code
however you want. I'm exporting this function.
I can then import
Scotland,
and then we can just layer on these
bindings, right, to add of course, many services
as as we want. So Yeah. Absolutely.
Or you can indeed you can define the
Restate dot service in the other file and
import that, all that sort of thing. The
only thing you need to be cautious of
is when you are trying to just have
a client for a service,
you generally wanna make sure you're only importing
types
and don't import the whole file because otherwise
at runtime, you could be importing all of
the handlers,
which maybe doesn't matter. But if you have,
like, a large mono repo, it will start
to matter.
So this is actually also quite similar to
CRPC the way we've approached it.
Alright. I'm just gonna make this different so
we can call these.
Mhmm.
Well, I don't know how to get a
whiskey emoji.
There we go. I had to giggle it.
That's unbelievable. Yeah. The movie picker wasn't working.
Idea.
I wonder if I could just have said
whiskey emoji,
mister AI.
Woah.
Okay.
That's very cool. I don't have any AI
systems. So
Yeah.
Copilot is fantastic.
I happen to in to explore
other ones, but because I was writing Versus
code, I just Mhmm. It's it's For sure.
Okay. So
let's go back to the documentation. Right? So
we did this, and then all we need
to do to run this new service is
to do an NPM run app dev. Now
the app dev, I'm assuming, is just a
script in our package. Yep. Yep. It's using
TS node dev.
K.
So NPM
NPM
run app dev.
Now is is that enough? Are we are
we are we working?
No. Because we need to run Restate. Otherwise,
it would be quite a magical library for
all the things that I said without running
anything else. But, unfortunately, no. That's that's another
thing.
Right. Well, I think this is this is
cool for people to to understand. With Restate,
you need
a Restate server,
and then your your functions,
your services, your workflows, those are all deployed
by you where wherever
you want. I use the workers.
But yeah. Okay. Exactly. Yep.
And
yeah. So in that sense, we can sometimes
look a bit like an API gateway.
So or a little bit like a service
mesh even.
So but I just sometimes people really don't
like these these kind of concepts, so it's
it's I never know whether to mention them.
But something like a durable API gateway or
a durable service mesh might be a good
way to think about Restate.
Alright. So now it's telling us you need
a server.
Now this is where things are gonna get
interesting.
Is that a static, like, a pile binary?
It is. Is that gonna it should That's
fine. Static is okay.
Static is should be Muzel. Yeah.
This is a real test to see if
this works on a next machine.
Oh my goodness. Yeah. That's great. Yeah. Okay.
Cool. Nothing better than we are are fine.
The minute there's any dynamic linking, I mean,
I just say goodbye and we say, we'll
meet you in the pub next week or
about something. But
Yeah. Okay. So we have a Restate server
running
on 000
binding port eighty eighty. We have our JavaScript
Express Lake server
running here on ninety eighty. So now we
need to do a little bit of glue
magic. Yeah.
And
as it's telling us here, I need to
do this, yeah, MPX, but we have to
register our deployment with the Restate server.
Exactly. Yeah.
And what let me maybe expand on what
deployment means,
and this is a very overloaded term in
distributed systems, I suppose. For us, a deployment
is referring to, like, that that physical
location at which services run, but many services
might run there. So your deployment might be
a Lambda ARN
or a URL to a Cloudflare worker or
a local host port, but but it's
completely unrelated to what services might exist.
So you
have a Restate Cloud setup, it looks like,
and you're currently configured. So you need to
do Restate
config use end for local, and then it
will start talking to your local Restate service
instead of your cloud service.
We're getting ahead of ourselves.
There we go. Right. I was just gonna
blow away that older entry, but that's
nicer.
Cool. Alright. So it's telling us it wants
to create a deployment.
There are two services that want to be
added, Greater and Scotland.
It gives us the inputs and output values
for these, and we can choose to accept
or deny. So we now have two services
deployed to Restate server being delivered via whatever
means we want.
Easy. Job done.
Alright. We're we're just getting to the easy
stuff. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
Alright.
So
I thought, oh, I'm surprised to have Carl.
That's good. Okay. So we could do Carl
to the Restate server. And this is just
the gRPC. Right? We're just doing
yeah.
Except no proto. I should have already said
this. When we first started Restate, there was
a lot of proto stuff and we just
quickly realized that the developer experience is really
bad in most languages.
So it's it's everything's just JSON, essentially.
We we don't actually this Restate service does
not server does not inspect at all what
the bodies are, so it just gets passed
to the SDKs. But the SDKs by default
will use JSON and put up.
I
do like that it's issued to be based
and not proto. It does simplify Yeah. Yeah.
Was such a nightmare.
Yeah. Pavel's in the chat saying that that
binary is a statically 1.1 binary that's apparently
hot off the presses. I'm sure I think
it's today or last yesterday evening that it
came out. Yeah. Sweet. I like bleeding edge.
So we got our high, but now, of
course, I'm gonna test our Scotland One. So
pop back over.
What did I call it?
I think it's Scotland slash greets. No? Oh,
no. Scotland slash Scotland. Scotland.
Way. Nice. Nice. I
mean, there's not a lot to that, but
I think what's really powerful is just what
we're getting there, that bedrock of just a
system that we can now build. I don't
want to say anything, but I'm gonna say
almost anything on. Right? Question
from Russell in chat.
If you stop the process, do need to
reregister? No. So Restate is, like, stateful,
of course. I guess that's how it works.
So not only do you not need to
reregister services, but if you stop the process
halfway through an invocation
and resume Restate, the invocation will complete.
So you should be able to halfway through
a request kill
Restate service,
the underlying service,
the whole machine, the whole data center,
and start everything back up again, and it
should finish. Now, obviously, if you had an
HTTP request open,
we but not magical. We can't currently keep
the TCP connection open. But when we have
multiple reset instances as part of a distributed
architecture,
you would be able to kill any of
them except for the one you're connected to.
But everything will always finish.
Can we demo that in a special way?
I've got an idea. Right? Yes. Yes. Yes.
We can use it. We can use a
Restate CLI to actually
and I can't remember the command, so please
help me out here. How do I list
the invocations?
It'll be in l s.
And there should be a way to watch
or you can just do watch dash n
one.
There we go. Okay. That was easy.
I like it, mate. Like, I always quote
myself, and I feel so cringey when I
do it. Right? But the best developer experience
is where I can be successful with intuition
rather than informed decisions, and that was intuition.
So Yeah. Props. Yeah. So we can call
Scotland again, and it's too fast for the
invocation to even show that there. Right? So
Yep. Let's add a new let's modify Scott
because one of the things we can do
is not respond
right away.
Yep.
So we could do and, again, I'm gonna
mess this up. Sleep.
And this is measured in milliseconds. So what
is five no. What is one minute in
milliseconds?
50,000.
50 thousand?
60 Yeah.
I was about to look really stupid there.
So
and let that that's a bit high. Let's
go with two seconds first before I go
show in
Yeah. What I'm trying to show. So if
we do that, how's that? I'd have to
redeploy my service.
No. Do maybe just needed the NPM dev
to rerun?
Should've worked.
Maybe not
on a well, it's not a watch. Maybe
it's not respawning correctly. Yeah.
Okay. But it seemed to think it'd been
modified.
Should we go back? Oh, oh, wait.
JavaScript.
You've been writing to Restate. Yeah.
So now we have our two second delay.
So let's bump this up, and let's say
thirty seconds is how long it's gonna take
us to stop the Restate server, bring it
back. Now we're not gonna get a response
to the CLI, but we should see the
implications. Right?
So We should see the implications. Exactly. Yep.
Alright. So
thirty seconds.
No.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And why don't we start with
not stopping Restate? Why don't we just start
stop the service? Because it can be cool
to watch the HTTP actually finish if you
stop the service. Ah, okay.
You close that. So we have our implication
here,
which just tells us that things are okay.
We can restart that service.
So you might wanna do
once we have the ID, we can also
do in describe, and you'll get a little
bit more information about it.
Anyway, it's about to run. So Yeah. That
And it will continue the sleep. But what's
interesting here, it's not gonna continue the sleep
from the start because that would be really
annoying because then if you keep failing, it's
just gonna do the sleep, like, with the
original wake up time.
Mhmm. So you actually shouldn't affect how the
curl appears at all, the fact that you
stopped the service.
And in fact, we could demonstrate that by
just printing out.
I I I don't know if I'm teaching
people how to, like, suck eggs. Right? But
So if you you should use context dot
console dot log, I think.
Yes.
Alright. Interesting. So logging is an interesting one
because how does Restate work?
It actually does run the function from the
start. It
just fills in all the sort of meaningful
side effects from what happened last time. And
that means that if you just do a
console dot log, it will usually log again
on resumption.
If you use context dot console dot log,
it will usually not, but it it just
it still can in some situations. Let's see.
Okay.
So here,
we have You can see that's the first
invoke. Yeah.
We can shut that down.
Yep. We can just, you know, do something
for ten seconds. I'm just trying to make
sure that we that comes back just in
time for that thirty second. Yeah. Exactly.
Alright.
It's been long enough, so we can restart
that.
It's gonna do the magic.
K. It's getting resumed. It didn't do the
original log again, which is cool.
Oh, yeah. I don't even think about that.
Of course. Yeah. There we go. 37. Yeah.
Exactly. 17 to 30. That is that not
magical?
Like Yeah.
That is the essence of it. This is
the essence of function.
It's ridiculous. Yeah. It's just Yeah. Coding has
never been this easy. This is just joy
in my face. This is what pure joy
looks like.
Absolutely.
And then what's even cooler, right, is so
let's say that we deployed this on a
Lambda.
It wouldn't sleep at all. Like, the process
wouldn't wait for a millisecond. It would just
immediately stop. And then thirty seconds later, it's
a completely new Lambda invocation. What's cool about
that is the way that Lambda is built
is, like, each invocation is really, really cheap,
and you just pay for, like, milliseconds.
So you're getting something a lot closer to
the Cloudflare worker primitive where you pay for
CPU time and you don't pay for IO
time, which in practice on Lambda is impossible.
But this is something we, like, want to
help people get to on Lambda because Lambda
is such a great platform.
So, I mean, I don't wanna get into
the depths of it. Right? But I have
always been curious. How are you hydrating this
function to a point that it can,
like,
jump through to that next stage? Like, what
So every line is right.
We're not doing any magic. We're not saving
stacks or stuff like that because that will
never work when you change your code. It
will just the whole thing with a segfault.
We still run every line of code,
but
we
are sort of injecting the value. So when
you do a context dot run, we're gonna
be like, oh, we did that before, so
we'll just immediately return the value that we
saved. When you do a sleep,
we are figuring out how much time we
actually need to wait for.
When you do context.contel.log,
we check, are we replaying?
By which, I mean, we're zipping through the
function to the point that we left off.
If we're replaying, we just don't emit any
logs. But if we're not replaying, then we
will.
So these are So is that just like
memoization
based on our invocation key and some representation
of this line of code? Well, that's exactly
right. It's it's memoization
of of a journal. A journal is just
a list of operations that you completed, but
the actual number is very small. I mean,
it's basically runs,
sleeps,
calls to other services,
get and set. So writing an SDK is
basically implementing a state machine over these operations.
But the fundamental thing is you are writing
this log.
The log must be stored by Restate successfully
before you continue,
and then our job is to give you
back that log as quickly as possible on
resumption and therefore have a very low overhead.
And so there's this logs per invocation,
but also Restate itself is a massive distributed
log, And all of those little logs kinda
filter into that and create one big log
for your entire system.
And it's very pretty, really.
But, yeah, that's how it works.
Okay.
So
we we obviously don't have a a plan
for what we're gonna demo, but we started
to say we. Right? I've dragged this down
to Scottish team here. So now I'm thinking,
can we write and I don't know if
this is interesting or too trivial, but say
a flow where we can use signals to
say, a whiskey, drink a whiskey, drink a
whiskey till it falls over after so many
whiskeys. Like, show a stateful workflow where we
are
sending events
or messages to then change the output of
the workflow.
Okay.
Sounds
good. Does that show enough, or should we
just go with one of the the demos,
the examples?
I mean, I was also wondering, do you
have any because you're running recent production. Right?
Do you have any anything that you actually
wanna build for Rawkode? I mean, is that
if maybe we could be helpful in some
way?
I do. I'm now just worried that I'm
gonna have to give people context and we
have Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, man. I mean
okay. Let's
what what we can right, is that I'll
show you the one that we have deployed,
and I can tell you what I'm doing
next.
So Mhmm.
Projects Academy
and RPC.
So I started off content.
This is gonna turn into, like, a you
help me session, but whatever. That's great, though.
No?
So
like I said earlier, I implemented
the user activation story. Now
the way I thought I was gonna do
this, and it it goes against everything I
wanted to do. So I have changed tack
a little bit. As I thought, I'll just
have an RPC
system,
which is, you know, publicly browsable,
rpc.RawkodeAcademy,
and you just get this web picture. It's
a Astral website that is deployed to Cloudflare
functions and pages
where I have pages configured for the Restate
entry point,
which is just me making sure I can
pass on requests via the different handlers to
Restate. Like, nothing magic there. It's not that
important.
But
we do have this user registered event,
which can come in, and I'm using some
trigger dot dev and some Restate here. So
I'll try not to go on it too
much. Right? But we have a web hook
from Workhorse,
which is closed source thing, which I didn't
think I would use until I see that
you get your first million daily
monthly active users for free. And I'll say,
I'm never gonna have more than a million,
so that's just free.
Yep. And I like free stuff.
Mhmm.
Where we have a Restate client, and then
depending on the event that we get, we
are
using
our handlers from Restate to trigger the user
created, which creates our workflow. And then when
we receive the email verification,
we then trigger that.
That's it. Yep.
These are just functions where we get the
client. We submit.
I'm assuming
people are easy to follow along with this.
There's nothing
weird or interesting happening here. It's worth noting
that these are clients
for users outside of Restate. So there's a
kind of a concept of, like, you're either
in a Restate service or you're just out
of the code. And, course, Restate services have
to interact with the rest of the world.
So what we do in TypeScript is we
have these typed clients
that give you basically the same API for
calling services,
except they actually go through the Restate ingress,
which are running on eighty eighty.
And as such, they don't have exactly the
same magical properties of, like, RPCs can't fail,
for example. They can still fail,
but they have support idempotency keys, so you
can generally come up with a very simple
RPC retry type mechanism.
And then, of course, once your request gets
into Restate Land, then it has all these
properties.
Yeah.
I guess worth pointing out is we are
using the idempotency key here. So Mhmm. Whenever
Rawkode sends us a webhook that is individually
keyed,
and we will never send an email twice
because we have this idempotency key in theory
and hopefully in practice.
That happened yet, so that's good. Now
the next thing is the actual,
you know, the registered handler itself. Now what's
cool here and but I don't wanna show
the code yet because just to make sure
people understand what's happening.
Anyone can register on Rawkode Academy.
But what we don't want to do is
send an email to someone who hasn't verified
to that as their email. That's gonna lead
to spam or abuse.
So,
I mean, we could just spend thirty seconds
on how we should do this without Restate.
Like, if you had to build this yourself,
what we should be doing?
So
I guess you can write into the database
once they've been verified.
That's easy, at least. So once they click
the verification link, that's gonna write a key
to database. Okay. No problem. The annoying thing
is that I have to, like, scan the
database to or, like, nightly or whatever to
see who's been verified in the last day
or whatever and send messages.
Or I can alternatively do some kind of
event emitter thing. So when I write that
key,
I also emit an event with, PubSub or
something.
And then I have a PubSub consumer running
in a process somewhere,
and that is the thing that actually sends
emails in response to those events. So probably
need to use a database and a queue
and have a few different handlers, like, interrelated
with each other.
Yeah. And there's there's challenges with that approach.
Right? And I'm hoping this is familiar to
people. If you go with the batch approach,
which is, like, when someone does verify the
email address, we are gonna write something into
table called verified with a time stamp. Every
night, you look for people to verify that
day, and you start sending emails.
Not a great approach. Who wants a verified
who wants a email twenty four hours later.
Right? I said, it's not cool.
Yep. The the real time approach, you've got
two ways of doing that. One, you can
do CDC on the database.
That requires more configuration,
set up pub subs, all that stuff. Or
you write to Kafka, but then you've got
the dual rate problem, which is well covered
in a federated systems and that can you
publish it to Kafka without confirm that it's
been activated in the database because you can't
do a transaction across two different systems? So
it's a such a simple
problem on the surface, but actually doing it
in a resilient way
requires effort and due care.
And here's the function. So there is a
lot going on here because I've been playing
with context set and phases and trying to,
you know, just explore Restate in a bit
more detail.
But all I the only line of code
that is important here is that when a
user is registered, we use this durable promise.
And I'm just waiting for an event on
this user ID that says that that user
has verified their email.
That's it. That's that's that entire system that
we just described.
And then everything after that is just me
sending an email, which is run
handled via context dot run so that it
is hopefully only ever gonna run one. Well,
do you see guaranteed to only ever run
once? I'm not sure. So this is impossible
because
you could get to the last line of
the function and the process could die, and
and we we just don't have any information
to know whether it ran or not. What
we say is that after there's been a
successful completion that's committed to Restate and we
move on to the next step, it will
never run again.
And this basically just makes item potency a
lot
easier to reason about.
In this case, I think it is technically
possible that you could send the email twice.
And I think if recent accepts an item
code as a key,
you could just inject one in there, and
that would solve that problem.
Yeah. I mean, the challenge is I'm running
this in the cloud for workers, which don't
cover guarantees that my worker won't be killed
or whatever. So, yeah, there there's
and that could be a problem. I think
it should still be possible
if you do, context dot rand dot u
u I d, then you get a u
u I d and that will stay the
same. And then you can pass that on
to to resend. But, I mean, yeah, also,
resend probably can't guarantee it without some kind
of inbound item urgency key. No. Technically,
it's just not possible without a without a
state identifier to prevent emails from being sent
twice.
But it's as close to
guaranteed as we're gonna get. I'm gonna I'll
I'll say that. I'm quite happy to go
in there. If
want, if you're not Absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. But
I just love so, again,
that's just how I guarantee that we don't
send an email to our users There's no
pops up. There's no CDC. There's no writing
to external data sources.
It's just a promise waiting for an event.
And I think that is just Yep.
But it basically it is the pops up
approach that we discussed. I mean, Restate is
essentially splitting your handler
into
a before event received step, which would be
one handler. Otherwise,
an event receiver
and then what to do when the event
is received. And it's got the KV in
there, like the KV read and write. It's
got the event reserve receive
and send, but it's just all in the
same handler. And that I guess that's the
that's the magic really, but it it's still,
like, the best in class approach, I guess.
Yeah. There's no hacks. We're still just doing
pops up. We haven't invented, like, a new
distributed systems approach. We just kind of give
a new different API, I guess, if that
makes sense.
Yeah. That makes sense to me.
So the bet that I hadn't showed here
is we just added
a new I don't know if you call
it functions, endpoints, whatever,
to this,
which just resolves that promise for us, and
then I'm triggering that
by just pulling out the client and calling
that as a function. I mean, it is
So this this named promise thing is, like,
a really handy feature of the workflow primitive
in particular, and that's that's kinda what we
created workflows for us to have this concept.
But we in general, in Restate, we have
these things called awakables,
and they're basically, like,
promises that you can share between services, and
they can be resolved with any value or
rejected with an error. So you could pass
around awakable IDs and basically have, like, really
complicated async processes between services, and and awakables
can be
also
resolved at the ingress. So you can have,
like, an inbound web hook that results awakable.
But the special case, like, the simplest special
case of of awakables is in this workflow
setup where you're mostly trying to communicate between
handlers of the same workflow. And for most
purposes, that is really, really, like, easy and
kind of simple. And I guess our approach
is we wanna make it possible to build
anything. Like, you can actually build a distributed
queue, for example, on top of Restate using
wakeables.
We wanna make it possible to do anything,
but we wanna make it easy to just
kind of do a workflow that does simple
things and not have to worry about, like,
creating complicated processes,
essentially.
Awesome.
Alright. So that leads us on to the
next step. It's that I've had decided
this isn't good enough. And for not not
Restate.
Let me clarify.
My deployment mechanism here is I'm essentially built
in this monolithic RPC
deployment where if I break it, I'm actually
breaking a whole bunch of different handles. Now
we get guarantees and result resiliency by going
through
Restate.
Mhmm. But everything else in my system is
deployed as individual workflow workers, and that's the
approach that I started to take when I
was looking at my technology service.
So if we pop back up
this is where I'm worried about just oversharing
on what's actually happening here.
Okay. No worries. But any service that we
have
gets boiled down to a data model, a
read model, and a write model. The write
model is all handled via RPC.
So
just tell me if I'm glossing over anything
too much here. Oh, that makes sense. We
have a a schema defined in Drezel,
and we're using the Drezel Valley bot
plug in for everyone who's not aware of
what that is. Valley bot is like Zod.
It gives us TypeScript types that we can
reuse in other parts of the system. So
Okay. While this data model allows me to
write to the database, I'm actually not handling
the rights
and the service for reasons I can
I I can get into if we wanna
go into it deeper? Mhmm. But just though
we have a schema here, and then the
read model is all delivered via graph based.
Graph based is the GraphQL
Mhmm.
Front end kind of thing where I could
just say I have I have this type.
This is the query I wanna satisfy,
and it does it does it does all
the jobs. The resolver for this is
using the Dresol client to query the table
and done. Now the reason
this is over the more complicated than I'm
getting into is that
in some cases in fact, let's just show
this off because this is where things get
a little weird.
Now most people would have shows
service, which I do,
which has all of my shows on my
YouTube channel.
Mhmm. I then have a people service, which
has all of the people that have been
guests. And the reason I separate these things
is so that the schemas are small,
migrations are nonexistent,
and I can replace the service. Like, the
cloud Objects,
basically. They're a little bit like virtual objects.
But then I needed to then say, people
can be a host of a show.
So I needed a new service for that.
Now what Graphbase does is it actually allows
me
to define fragments of these types and does
the aggregation at the front.
So what I'm saying here is that we
have a person which is not resolvable
because this is not the person in service,
but we know that they have an ID
and that's how they're keyed.
So it's a foreign key essentially. Exactly. Yeah.
We're doing distributed foreign keys across services.
Then the show is a service, which is
also keyed with an ID.
It's also not resolvable, although we don't mark
it as not resolvable because we have this
new property that we want to add
to it.
Mhmm. And what we're saying is we want
to people to be able to create a
host switch resolves to a person using this
resolver.
What
that means is I get
this very cool API, and I'll just log
in to GraphQL quickly because I don't have
a GraphQL client available right now.
Mhmm.
See, this is the rabbit hole I was
worried about going down. No. No. It's okay.
This is pretty cool. I think it's so
interesting to look at, like, real world real
world Restate usage.
Okay. So here's my single API where I
can do a query, and I can say,
give me all my shows
where the host and get me the
the forename.
This is where it's not gonna work. Right?
Don't do it to me.
Ah. Oh, there you go. Great. But we
didn't get the show name. So
so here we are. Right? We have Rawkode
Live, and we have a host with a
four name of
Mhmm. Oh, yeah. It's just it's just weird
formatting.
There we go. That must be good. So
that's actually creating the show's service,
the people service,
and then the aggregation service injecting all that
thing. So this is distributed join, essentially. You're
you're joining across two different distributed services. Yeah.
Ex exactly.
So And is this all hitting the same
underlying database or are they No. No. No.
Every service has its own lib sql, terso
db. So SQL
lite, which makes local development experience very nice.
Okay. Got you. Now this presents a problem.
And this is why Restate is such a
big part of my architecture now. Because
if I want to create a new show,
a new person, and a host of a
show,
that is actually a multi
step. Right? I have to create the show,
create the person, and then say that that
person is then a host of a show.
But I can't just insert
values into a table anymore.
I restate different services. I see. Yes. Of
course. Yeah. Yeah. So Restate becomes the orchestrator
of these rights so that when I do
have
GraphQL endpoint and the same, it's a mutation
and, say, we say create show.
I'm not gonna actually do this. It's not
gonna work. Hosts,
and that could be Rawkode is the idea.
Like, whatever.
This has to have a resolver that can
create the show, but then has to guarantee
that the Rawkode exists and then create it
with another server.
But it gets quite complicated from our right
perspective, but I'm okay taking on that burden
because I get the read API that I
want for the website, the platform, the apps,
all of the automation. Oh, you. Great. Very
cool.
So I know we're we're deteriorating the fuck
now, but let me go back to the
technology.
Really understand the problem now. I I was
waiting for it to get to, like, the
restate bit. I totally understand. This is a
dual right. You've disaggregated.
Yeah. I mean, Ahmed's in the comments saying,
just do the whole thing and reset, mate.
Problem solved.
That is actually a dual right. But
you still have foreign I mean, you still
have foreign keys and re I mean, we
still have this concept in Restate. You still
have, like, IDs and, I mean, you know,
keys for virtual objects, and you still have
to read across two different services and write
across two different services. The difference would be
the right sort of can't fail,
I guess, in a
they can't transiently fail. So if you risk
right call 1 and then call 2 to
do the first right and the second right,
you don't have to have a lock or
a transaction or anything like that because Restate
would guarantee they would run to the end.
But you can still do this even if
they're external systems, even if you have to
talk to these services that aren't running at
Restate. It's just easier if they do run
at Restate, of course. Well,
we are quickly running out of time, and
you've given me lots of fit for thought
there. I'm gonna suggest that maybe there's
a part two where we can actually dive
into how we could put in a virtual
object approach and and build something out.
But I'll finish my train of thought and
just where I am with the technology service.
Now Restate as an opinionated about where my
services are deployed. The fact that I was
putting them into a single RPC deployment was
for convenience at the start, but now I'm
like, actually,
what I need is inside this technology service
is a Restate directory,
which has a single handler, which I deploy
to cloud for workers and register with the
server. And that way, I can share
my
Drezel value dot schema, which allows me to
do the input validation
before doing the right to the Turtle database.
And that's gonna be my model moving forward
for every single right within the system. So
every write is going through Restate. Nothing will
go through GraphQL.
It's all gonna be RPC.
But instead of having a single RPC service,
I'm gonna have many, many RPC services that
Restate as the orchestrator of.
Yep. Yep. And do you think that these
rights will still go
Restate and then a non Restate service and
then Terso, or would you be happy for
them to be
talking to the database directly from Restate? In
which case, things I think would be a
lot easier. I'm gonna have Restate talk to
the database, and we can I mean, we've
got twenty minutes? Okay. So you We could
probably do this thing. About convert yeah. I
think we could convert one of these
Because the Dressel's client is regular. Object. Right?
So and
so let's just say we had
Restate.
I'll be bold now because I do have
buttoned this dev in.
And
I'm just gonna delete that. Holding one. Why
don't you try the there should be a
BUN template. Oh, have you used the BUN
template for Restate? No.
There should be if you do Restate example,
like, the CLI. Oh, there is. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. You should try that.
Well, I don't have the CLI.
But I'm installing MPX. No?
Oh, sorry. You're in a different directory, so
you have, like, totally different tools now, don't
you?
Oh, Restate there for it.
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
That's it.
Okay. So we can do ban
run
at least date.
Example
done, I think.
Let's just pull it up. So
No. I don't think it's used there because
you don't have the CLI yet there.
Maybe I don't know where it would be
used.
Operate.
We can just run help. Just give it
a try.
Oh.
Because it's in my globals.
Oh, no.
That looks right. There we go. Yes. Okay.
So it should be example.
Yeah. I think you just run example, and
then it will ask you.
You can just do example. It will ask
you what you wanna do.
Yeah.
TypeScript
Fun. Hello. Well, it's nice.
Alright.
Let's just I'm just gonna extract this up.
Won't pull it that way. Don't mind.
Don't know what temp does this the ZIP.
You don't need the ZIP. Don't worry.
Alright.
Okay. So now we have a Restate
reader service and button. Yeah. And I'll just
make sure that works.
So I should be able to do
I don't know what the script is for
BUN. It's just dev. Oh, there we go.
Dev. Alright. Okay. Unify
those. BUN install.
Yeah. Just got it running on another port.
Not that one, I think.
That one. Yeah.
Okay. Nice. Good. So now we have a
service. So now what we wanna be able
to do here
is called create
technology.
I don't think that's really important, but I
don't know.
Technologies
create.
And that's one step closer.
This could literally be the first public user
to just release 1.1. Yeah. I mean, yeah.
It's true. You sure you don't wanna do
this with Rust? No. I mean, I'm just
No. No. No.
Okay. So we already have types here. So
let's do import
from
Drizzle.
Drizzle
schema,
so
no.
I wouldn't normally import them like this.
I
would
but workspace it.
But
And are the Drizzle,
like, operations, like, when you do get and
set, are they sort of idempotent?
Like, how how does Drizzle do I guess,
is that transactional?
I mean, I could do it. But would
would it always be, like, create
create if not exists in this sort of
thing or up update or insert this sort
thing? I I think it's just doing an
insert.
Okay.
But, you know, we don't need to get
into the
technicalities of it right now.
Okay.
This gives us a TypeScript type.
I wonder if I can just do
Should be able to. Yeah.
Type off. Maybe import type. Or
There
we go.
And now we just have something where I
could say
technology.no.
We'll get to it in a minute. I'm
sure we can work it out. So Mhmm.
See, as a value, let's let's just
let's not get ahead of myself. Right? Let's
just take something. Because
what I could do now is I can
use my technologies and search schema.
We may have to look up the Drezel
docs.
There's a validate function.
Maybe I have to copy for whatever handler
you currently have. Right?
It's broken.
I'm actually because as you could tell, I'm
on a branch where I've been rewriting this.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Here. Create insert schema.
And then Oh, it's we can call pars
passing in the schema. Okay.
So
pars.
I'm gonna have to add Drizzle
Mhmm. To this. This is where I should
have done it as up on workspace.
That's what I get for being half assed.
I mean, I don't really need this package
dot JSON. Right?
I just need these
dependencies.
Yeah. Yeah. I shouldn't need it, but I
don't think so. As long as I'm than
me duplicating all of this. Now I know
there's cleaner, nicer ways to do this.
Let's just take that out.
Scripts is fine. Dependencies.
Dev dependency is probably okay.
But Yeah. But don't need anything.
Okay.
So
I could do we should be able to
run button install. It does appear directory.
Mhmm. This now means I can get parse,
which is probably morning because it's not used.
That's okay.
And and here, we can see
parse
like so. So now we know we have
a valid technology.
And I'll pull those docs back up. And
if we don't, I guess, we would usually
throw a terminal error, which is, like, telling
Restate
this is, like, never gonna succeed because the
input is
bad.
Yeah.
The problem we have
now is when I generate a type client
for the service, I'm not gonna get the
fields that I actually need to be able
to fill in. So I need to do
this, and I do need to solve that.
You need to solve the type of schema
thing. Yep. Yep. Yeah. I need to work
out that. So
but in theory, I should now be able
to do
if we import
knowledge's table,
Start my imports for me.
I was hoping that we'd move that here.
And Rusta would have done it for me.
Yeah.
Oh, that didn't even work. Right. Now we
can just say technologies
well, that's that this is the tape. That's
that's interesting. Okay.
Let me pull up my graph here. So
I've forgotten how to drizzle now. It's it's
too much pressure.
Oh, yeah. That looks right. Yeah.
That looks right. Okay.
Stop watching me. Alright. Okay.
Import
import
schema.
That might be the type you were missing
for oh, no. That could be the insert
schema.
That's the star.
So Oh.
Which is gonna have to go up one
more directory.
Yeah. No. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Schema.
So now this is actually d p
insert
and technologies table two. Okay.
No. This is untyped.
So
and it wanted an extra argument.
I'm just gonna use the docs because I
have no idea what I'm doing.
Users values.
So you do the table first and then
the right. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Done.
Nice.
So if that's the last step, you don't
even need to use a context dot run
because,
I mean, it's the last step anyway. It's
nothing afterwards would ever happen.
Yeah.
Well, that would work. That would kinda work.
And then if you need to do, like,
multiple
of these calls,
like, you're calling technologies create and then you're
calling something else dot create.
So technology says the easiest service, and it
doesn't have any dependencies. It just needs to
set a service. But, you know, if we
were doing a more complex example, like the
show hosts,
yes, we would have to first do a
query to make sure the show exists, make
a query to make sure the
person exists,
then do the answer, assuming they're not already
inserted into the thing. So there's all there
is a lot more logic. This is the
most primitive version of the right that we
could possibly do.
Yeah. What I'm curious about is where I
can get that typed work.
It could be a
No. That's just that's a actual table. So
Mhmm.
There must be a way to infer. Oh,
there is a infer function. Right? So
but I'm doing that with the
insert schema.
This is voodoo to me.
Yeah. Probably this TypeScript type stuff is that
when it when it's not working, it's, like,
impossible to figure out why. And when it
works, it's, like, so magic.
Yeah. I I don't think it's important for
the
the demo. Like, the fact that I have
this function, which I can now deploy and
register with the thing is is important. I
would love to be able to run it.
I don't think it's gonna work right now.
And it's more than about my Libiscale client,
which I've not seen before.
I'm not sure. Is that just because of
this TS config?
Yeah. Maybe I haven't imported it.
Like, because Well, I have a I moved
it in the title. Right?
So And you definitely have it at the
root. So we're we're using this TS config.
So I might be able to just nuke
your Restate one.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. You probably didn't need that.
Restart Oh, yeah. That fixes the yeah.
Yeah. Nice.
And I curious if that fixes. No.
I can get to that type, but I
can't
I'm not quite getting the exact type information
that I expect here, but I think that's
possible because of this any type.
Like, if I break everything,
this definitely fails. Ah, okay. Yeah.
So, yeah, there's something that I'm gonna have
to work out. I'm not gonna be able
to do it in nine minutes on this
session. Alright. That's fine. That's totally fine.
I think that's pretty cool.
And it's something I need to get working
today anyway. This was after the session. This
is what I was gonna be working on
for the rest of the day.
And I feel the point here, right, is
that, like, you haven't really written, in this
case, the service in any in any different
way. And the main benefit we're getting from
from Restate here is just for the communication
between services that that becomes, like, exactly once
guaranteed, essentially.
And if you can just make that d
b dot insert step idempotent,
that's I think that's important as well. If
you can do that, then the whole thing
that that's basically the root of the distributed
systems problem here. As long as the database
right is unimportant,
everything else should work with Restate.
Yeah. I mean,
I can start a transaction,
and then it becomes an item. At least
it's either gonna success or fail. It's gonna
be atomic. And then that Yeah. Atomic is
easy with databases, but the critical thing is
that it's, it's like an update if if
exists. It's like insert or update is that
one. I'm I'm not a ShysQL expert, but
I think that's the critical thing. It needs
to not fail if the exists. If the
row exists. I want it to fail.
Oh, you do? Okay. But what if, let's
say, it gets past the DB right, but
then TURCE fails or whatever, and then it
wrote to the database, but it never returned
200.
Then Restate will retry. Right?
Then we'll write it again, and then it'll
fail permanently.
So,
yeah, why why why would it need to
fail if if the rows are already there?
Isn't that 200 okay? Like, we're out and
put it and we're okay.
Yeah. I suppose we can do an answer
on update. Like, that would Yeah. Would work.
Generally, I would say that's better.
Does support that anyway on conflicting data update,
and then we specify.
Okay. Great. So that's really all you need
for this to be, like, a well behaved
Restate service. So the idea is that, like
Like so. We we are kind of saying
here that failures are all transient failures should
be retried. The other type of non transient
failure that we shouldn't retry is the one
where it is valid as false. In that
scenario, I think we should throw a terminal
error
and then just say, look. The request parameters
are wrong.
Sweet.
Alright. I am gonna be sat here for
the next three hours at least working on
tidying this up because I'm now in a
position where I was like like,
I could put this in a Restate folder,
but,
I mean, there's nothing yeah. This has got
us on No. I'm not knowing what, you
know, what other kind of services you need
really than these kinds of services because yeah.
I mean, it's but our hope is that
we make every handler a bit better. Some
handlers, make, like, a million times better so
that every handler is, like, enough improved that
it's kind of worth using.
Yeah. I'm very excited to play this now.
This is this is a lot lot for
my setup. So I
will definitely be doing some videos once I
get this all working on
how this all fits together. But my my
main objective was data model, read model, write
model. And between graph based, Restate, and Drezel,
I have those three components.
And I I am very excited once I
Mhmm. Deal with the TypeScript thing here, once
I deal with that.
I agree. And it's a it's a simple
thing. I'm gonna go after this session. I'm
gonna pop this back to to Big Face
mode.
Once I go through the Dursle docs, I'm
sure there's a page on getting that that
type and using it as a TypeScript type,
and that's the final the final straw. So
Exactly.
Yeah. I mean, you could actually have something,
by the way, that sort of there's there's
like a concept of high order services. So
you could actually have a thing that just
takes a table and turns it into a
Restate service that does the crud that you've
just shown. So it does validation,
returning a terminal error if it doesn't validate,
and then does the update and or up
sorry, the insert or update. You can have
this that just converts any table into any
Restate service
and not even have to write this slide
boilerplate each time.
That could be kinda cool.
Yeah.
I I don't fully understand that. But
The point being is, like, the service that
you've just written, it would look exactly the
same if the table was different. Right? It's
just accept an input, check that the input
matches the schema for this table that's previously
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then do the update.
So there's no reason to write it for
each one. You can just have a single
implementation of, like, for the a function that
turns a table into a Restate service, then
you could just bind all of those services
for each table.
You only have to write that handler once.
Oh, yeah. I mean, I it could be
a generic handler that takes a test. Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Oh, wow. That's pretty
slick.
Yeah. Yeah. It should work. I mean, for
the simple use cases where it's
If it's just crud. I mean, if you're
doing some kind of other complex stuff, then,
yeah, you would still write the handler. But
but, yeah, there's no point writing these crud
handlers over and over again. You can just,
you can just you're sort of writing like
a
you're kind of converting a database table into
a Restate service. So you're handling all of
the types of failure, like schema being invalid,
the the write failing,
and those become, Restate
services as errors as RPC errors. And then
once it's an RPC handler, you have all
of Restate's properties, like the RPC will happen
once and will always complete and things like
that, and you they'll go through invocations. So
this is a really nice thing, and something
we would really like in the future is
maybe even Restate can even do SQL operations
for you. So you wouldn't even need to
write such a wrapper, but you can sort
of do context dot SQL,
and we would manage the transaction
and guarantee that it only happens once and
this kind of matches. So nice. Yeah. Watch
this space, but we would love to do
that.
Alright. I have taken up enough of your
time for the Rawkode Academy self help program.
So
Well, let's do a part two because this
is actually really interesting.
Yeah. I'll get a few steps forward. So
I so we get to that point where
I think it's more interesting for the viewer
to see a more complete system rather than
what is right now very early
prototype proof of concept. But I like that
generic handler idea. I can share that in
my BUN workspace,
and the simple things can just pull that
through, and that's gonna be amazing.
And then I can get on to the
more advanced use cases where we have real
workflows with real challenges.
And then we can look back and say,
okay.
Here's where we are. What's the next steps?
Yeah. Well, I I know it's gonna be
worth it. Yeah.
Alright.
Something I'd like to finish on
is just to talk about what's next. Now
Restate is already a one point o release.
You've got that seed funding.
You've mentioned context or SQL, which doesn't exist
but could exist. Maybe you could share a
bit of light on what's on the road
map. What are you working on as a
company and a team?
Yeah. So I would say 85% of the
resources right now at Restate are are working
on distributed runtime.
So, like,
you know, for context, we have come from
the world of, like, building distributed systems, and
we have designed Restate from the ground up
to be distributed. But right now, we've been
running a bi a single binary today. Right?
And that binary is a single process. And
a lot of the things that we're talking
about are way easier in a single process.
We haven't taken those easy routes, but we
need to prove that now. We are distributing
Restate. We're making it work in high availability
setups, so, like, active, passive,
but also,
like, fully distributed sharded setups, like, ten, twenty,
50 nodes.
And, yeah, the designer always accounted for that
at the start, but to actually build, like,
a distributed system with virtual consensus
from scratch and Rust is obviously a huge
amount of work. I would say we are
now in the last stages of that, but
it's kind of taking up all energy.
And this is really exciting because
we want it to be possible that you
can kill half of the restate instances or
lose a DC or whatever and have milliseconds
of fail over time or even no fail
over time. That's that's really important as part
of our mission.
So, yeah, that's that's what I'm excited about.
I'm really, really hopeful that we'll have something
there, like, very soon.
Nice.
Awesome.
Any final words before we depart for today?
No. I think we covered everything. Had a
really awesome time, so thanks very much. It's
been brilliant. Really appreciate you taking the time
to, you know, share your story, the Restate
story, and even help me debugging and planning
some future Academy features. So, again, thank you
so much for your time. We'll definitely reach
out and get a part two in the
future, and I'm excited to see what you
and the team at Restate too.
Awesome. Well, thanks very much. I'll see you
next time. Yeah. For everyone watching, thank you
very much. Feel free to say something in
the comments as we bid you a do.
Have a great day and the rest of
the week. Bye.